people
do a very good job at finding patterns
in things especially things that they're
not familiar with and today since it's
valentine's day we're looking at
astronomical objects that have a shape
of a heart
so you might not think it but on the
surface of mars we've actually found
quite a few hearts these are
various images that were taken from the
mars global surveyor
on the surface so in each of these you
can actually see
clearly the shape of a heart most of
them are dips so they're actually
depressions in the surface so in this
one you can see clearly this heart
structure and it's a depression in the
ground and if the light's coming from
the left you can see the cliff right
here has a dark side and it's
eliminating this side of the of the
cliff
this one i particularly like because
it's a crater with a heart that's in the
middle of the crater so the crater goes
down into the surface and then the heart
actually pops up from the center so it
forms a mesa this is an example of how
human beings love to find patterns in
anything that they can just like when we
stare up at the sky on a sunny day
try to find patterns in the clouds
in astronomy the same thing kind of
happens and
interesting looking objects tend to get
nicknames
one class of interesting objects are
called nebulae and these are big clouds
of gas
in our galaxy
and they're where stars are born so we
often call these nebulae by interesting
nicknames based on what they look like
there's the hourglass the cat's eye the
owl the lagoon nebula the boomerang but
today for valentine's day we're showing
you the heart nebula
so you can see this beautiful
heart-shaped pattern here
which is glowing hydrogen gas
that gas is glowing because in the
middle of this nebula is a knot of stars
so this is one of my favorite galaxy
pairs this is the antenna galaxies
and these are actually two separate
galaxies that are coming together
in a marriage
of
the two galaxies to become one
so maybe a billion years ago these were
actually separate galaxies and so
they've been orbiting each other and
getting closer and closer and you can
see now that the two are really coming
together to form one and you can see
these
wings of of stars and gas so it's called
the antenna galaxy because they think
these are the antennae that look kind of
like a bugs antennae
and
a more updated version of this with the
hubble space telescope is this image so
it just zooms in on that central region
and you can really see this nice
romantic heart shape
okay so we're going to move away from
hearts for the moment
but i am going to show you an image that
has something to do with valentine's day
this is probably one of the most
romantic
images made
if you think of romance not just being
about love but about big ideas the
connection with valentine's day is that
20 years ago
a little spacecraft called voyager 1
shooting out to the outer reaches of the
solar system
its its mission finished to explore the
planets was commanded to turn around and
take a family portrait of our solar
system and of course the connection with
valentine's day is that it was on
february 14 1990 20 years ago that this
little spacecraft was sent the
instruction to turn around its mission
completed and start taking a picture of
our of our solar system family
and this is the picture it took it was
four billion miles away from the sun
and it went and took 60 different
pictures stitched together here in this
panorama that capture almost all of the
members of our solar system family so
you see the the sun in the center earth
and venus very close by unfortunately it
missed out mars and mercury but it got
all the rest of the planets jupiter
saturn uranus and neptune aside from the
grandeur of this whole picture put
together
um it's really one particular frame of
this that really that captured the
public's imagination
and that is of course the portrait of
earth because that's that's our home and
so if we zoom in on that one little
picture
you're seeing a picture of earth from
four billion miles away
and earth
is this little tiny dot right in the
center
so the remarkable thing about this
particular image is that it really gives
us a perspective on our place in the
solar system and just how small and
insignificant our precious little home
is
this is a tiny little dot in this one
little picture and that's earth that's
our home
but really i'm just paraphrasing a great
scientist carl sagan here because he had
some much more profound words to say
about this
he said look again at that dot
that's here that's home that's us
on it everyone you love everyone you
know
everyone you ever heard of every human
being who ever was lived out their lives
he goes on to call it a moat of dust
suspended in a sunbeam
and that's absolutely true because
it is this little dot it happens purely
by chance to be caught on some reflected
light within the camera coming from the
sun